okay um i apologize if you are
mid-thought
i'm just mindful of time and i want to
make sure that we
get the whole picture together quite
literally okay so
if you're not quite there yet just pause
and look up because i don't want you to
miss
any crucial steps of logic okay let's
have a think about this
i've done a little bit of algebraic
working before i
leap to my diagram so let's just make
sure we know what we're doing here right
i've broken apart this single argument
the argument or quotient into two
separate arguments
it's the difference of the arguments so
there's the numerator or it was the
numerator
there's the denominator it was and then
on my
third line you can see what i've done is
i've factorized out
um a minus sign from each one right
because i'm trying to make clear like in
the first example you know how z minus
one was on the inside so one
was your reference point and then z
minus three three
was your reference point so with this z
minus
whatever that's what gives me there
the reference points that i need so
these things are fixed
and then z will move around them okay so
now i am ready to start putting on my
ign diagram where is minus two plus i
i'm going to be over here in the second
quadrant yeah now that we know in
advance
that these reference points are going to
be hollow circles i might as well plot
them
as hollow circles now so i'm going to go
ahead and put that one right
there
and then i've also got i just realized
it looks like an o but anyway we'll
run with it i've also got 2 plus 3i so
here's 2
and then i'm going to go up to 3 so i'll
put it there okay
hollow circles are ready now there's a
semi-circle or rather there are two
semi-circles that run through
these points if they're the ends of the
diameter right there's a semi-circle
that goes around
that way and a semi-circle goes around
that way okay
so i just need to think if i'm going
anti-clockwise
which one is my starting point can you
tell me
it's the first one right it literally
goes from the first one to the second
one wherever they happen to be
positioned okay
so i'm going to go anti-clockwise from
here to here
so very roughly speaking if you've got a
pencil there like if you're not graphing
in pencil
you are bananas because these are really
quite hard to do accurately from the
first time
um you're gonna have something that runs
sort of around here
right okay with that um you do that
lightly and then you sort of put it in
a little more closely now i have the
distinct advantage of having had a go at
this
earlier so there are some features that
i know about that maybe you have not yet
found
but we're going to find them together we
didn't do this for any others but what i
want
after this is two things number one the
cartesian
equation we've seen this before right um
this is
a complex equation z's and i's and all
that kind of thing i want something that
is just
x's and y's right how do i do that
well i need to know to define a
it's the same as if i'm defining a
circle right i need to know
the center of
my circle semicircle and i also need to
know what other piece of information
right here the radius thank you okay
center radius i'll be good to go
now i've given you because i'm nice like
that i've given you some nice points
here some nice coordinates right
because they're symmetrical about the
imaginary axis
when you take the middle that's why
you're on the imaginary axis itself
so you know that's going to be 0 for the
real component
what's the imaginary component it's
going to be halfway between
i and 3i so yes it is to
i so i've got the center that's good
and now i need to know the radius um
there's lots of ways you can find the
radius right
this would give you the radius or this
would give you the radius
is it a complicated calculation to work
out what the radius should be
it's not too hard right i mean yeah you
could just use the distance formula here
you've got
um you know these distances don't you
right that's two
well it's negative two going that way um
this distance here is
one thank you very much so this is a one
two use pythagoras with me come on
that's gonna be root
five fantastic there's my radius okay
so therefore from that argument i can
say the cartesian equation will be
take a breath something sorry actually
that's not
that's not in brackets uh x squared
because how do i think i haven't moved
anywhere
horizontally i'm on right on the center
plus
what's my y going to be because you know
where the center is right
it's been moved up two units very good
so i'm going to get y
minus 2 squared and then what's on the
right hand side
with the radius squared which in this
case is root 5
times root 5 you get five okay now
clearly this cartesian equation doesn't
tell you
everything because um that that is the
whole circle right but i don't want the
whole thing
i need to provide some words here to say
like you can't even put a um
a domain restriction on it either right
because if you said oh it's going to be
this part here you'll get a part on the
top as well right
so just having the diagram there is the
whole point now i said cartesian
equation
the other important information is the
intercepts
now if your diagram is incredibly
awesome like mine you may be able to
read off
your intercepts but generally you don't
want to have that
level of invest that level of conscience
confidence in your diagram and we
actually have an equation here
that will help us does this semi-circle
have
y-intercepts
yes it does okay and i can find it by
putting in x
equals zero right let's go ahead y
intercept
x equals zero here's the equation right
here
you're just going to get y minus 2
squared equals
5. can you care with that so y minus 2
is going to be equal to
[Music]
i'm taking the square root so plus minus
square root of 5
and then you add 2 to both sides which
gives you this
now i've got two solutions here because
i'm actually solving for the equation of
not a semicircle
i'm solving for the equation of a circle
so you expect two solutions
which one is the one that i want it's
got to be the negative one right because
it's it's lower you can see from your
diagram
right so i would say but
um y has to be less than two it's only
gonna be on the bottom side here right y
is less than two therefore y has to be
to take away
root five so that's my point down there
in fact i'll go ahead and i'll
mark that in two minus three five
three five again like two points
seven two points someone help me out
here three six so that's what this is
that's why it's so close right it's
negative
point three six right so two take away
root five
uh and then so i say it again uh minus
point two three six sorry got it right
got my decimal place mixed up i've got
my y intercepts
i need to find some x intercepts as well
so i'll do that
these are even nicer numbers when y
equals zero you can you might be able to
look at that
and tell me yeah have a look right you
get um
zero minus two squared so this becomes
x squared plus four equals five
yes x squared equals
one and in this case oh that's nice i
actually do want
both of these solutions because you can
see it from the diagram negative one
and one should put that one somewhere
clear so i don't mix it up with the
other one
okay now that i've got that all right i
actually need to fill this in i put it
dotted because i was not
confident at the beginning but i'm
pretty happy
with that there's a semi-circle i want
anti-clockwise
from the first point to the second